come on you have two more hot food
outlets i do i do i don't know what
ashley has bought me
but let's let's have a look okay so the
first one looks like a karaoke what the
which potato yeah yeah there's so what a
karaoke is it's kind of just like a
potato katsu right that's that's the way
to describe it
that is literally see-through
it's like minced meat katsu basically
okay i've never had this so essentially
you know what this is
this is literally a deep-fried hamburger
this is what this is
this is literally what this is a
deep-fried hamburger
this is look at that this this is this
is a basically a hamburger this is a
smell
you know what it smells like it reminds
me like pies in the uk it does
a little bit yeah it's like a minced pie
it has it has a very pie smell
oh my god god i don't know if you can
see this on camera but you the oil
has seeped gusting the oil has seeped
through to the table doesn't really
taste of anything
like meat and grease that's all i taste
there's like no seasoning oh my god this
tastes
like how how do you know what actually
you don't know
how do you eat something and just have
zero opinion about the taste
right yeah just nothing this literally
tastes like cardboard
because there's no taste in it at all
like you'd
like you'd expect some kind of the
burger to have some kind of seasoning on
it
this tastes like batter yeah granted
i've had really good mensch katsu and
this is definitely a weak sauce like
weak sauce compared to what i heard what
else did you get okay
okay you wanted you want to see this
yeah sure it's a spring roll
have you ever all gotten the spring roll
from here
look at that look at that this i i do
not stand this look at that
okay let's i'm gonna cut this up you
know this is this is
this you know it's not good when you're
cutting a spring roll and it turns flat
it's it's a soggy spring roll right
you know wow i i don't like spring rolls
in general
i i yeah i don't like spring rolls
they're way too oily for me
actually that's not bad at all how's it
taste how does it taste
it's quite fatty somehow like very fatty
you know what it's like
it tastes like a dim sum yeah oh a
little bit it's like the kind of
oil yeah it's like an oiliness of a dim
sum
it's like you know you know when you
because in the uk we have these like
party platter things
yeah you get from ice that's what it
looks like yeah so you thought you were
just gonna get a bite of just pure like
pastry whatever was it pastry is that
what it is oh yeah i think it's pastry
pastry and then just maybe like a crumb
of meat
yeah and like that's normally how it is
that's why i hate spring rolls but
that one was packed i you know i i i'd
get that i would actually honestly
honestly
i did not expect it to taste that good
it tastes like
yeah like you said like a mini dim sum
but in a spring roll pastry yeah
um wow that was that was not the taste i
was expecting
i thought they would somehow make this
one work and [ __ ] up the spring yeah
right
it was the opposite way around you
surprise us but there's there's tons of
stuff that we don't have here hot foods
like a change all the time like for
example lawson's has like
hot dogs that have like different
toppings like salsa there's like meat
i mean let's not forget as well about
the nikumans and the pizza monsters
right like that
yeah yeah one thing all of the
convenience stores yeah what's what's it
called just like a steamed bun yesterday
so like
you can get like the chinese steamed
meat buns cinnamon all the animes
yeah honestly all like all of the meat
buns and all three of the kombini's are
lit
and they taste really good they taste
way too good and yeah those are really
good i i [ __ ] with the hot dogs hot dogs
are pretty [ __ ] good
and at one point okay so they they also
go through
at all the chains they all go through
seasonal items at one point they had
like
like uh mini burritos my burritos
yeah like microwavable burritos that
were like they're
probably like proper burritos no
if there's one food item that i think is
really hard to get in japan or one
frequency
mexican food it's so hard to get good
mexican food in japan you can get
any other any other food i feel like
i've had i've gone to a restaurant
and i've been like yeah this is almost
yeah the only way you can get mexican
food is to go to like international
chains that just happen to be here right
yeah yeah and
and even then like we've been to some
mexican restaurants we can get rid of
this [ __ ] we've been to some mexican
restaurants and i've always felt
underwhelmed oh yeah it's always it's
always felt like the mexican
but it's sad because that's the best
you're gonna get yeah exactly exactly
we need more good mexican in japan i'm
putting that out there right now because
mexican
mexican food [ __ ] slaps i get really
sad because i watch on like youtube i
watch like those like
food insider where the [ __ ] they're
called like videos yeah the ten best
burritos in la and i'm like oh my god
all of them look
[ __ ] amazing um but yeah no i mean
there's there's other food items as well
that are hot like you can get actual
like full meals you can get instant
ramen which is
yeah like it's like a solid like frozen
broth i'm not really sure
it's like freeze-dried it's freeze-dries
block and basically when you microwave
it
it melts and makes a broth that's
actually like better than most of the
[ __ ] you'll get ever
in like america oh yeah yeah you know
even like some restaurants i've been to
that say ramen they're like definitely
not wrong
actually not bad um there's also you can
get
gaunt has one of them with us there's a
bunch of variations uh
lawson's does a ton of like i mean
there's there's pastas as well i
remember as well yeah the pastas are
lit pastas uh weird combinations of
pastas as well like stuff that like you
would never see
a very very japanese twist on italian
food
yeah what's a weird combination they
have they'll have like um
[ __ ] like egg and tomato sauce or
something that like i've like
yeah they put hot dogs in their pasta
some of the pastas literally look like a
kid's meal it's true it's true
they look like the dairy the like dairy
meal lunch pack lunchbox
you know when you get you're a kid and
you kind of make your own like sandwich
out of the
lunchables yeah that's what they that's
like the equivalent of putting into
japanese
uh sorry italian cuisine yeah lawson's
has like
a premium hot food section which is
doesn't include any of that pasta [ __ ]
right it's only japanese and
not normally fried food yeah but it's
there is udon and
we don't you don't know what it is
which is like udon is uh just like i
guess strips of
beef and then grilled and then put with
rice and you normally get like a sauce
or a mayo to dip it in
right nice and then butter which is my
favorite is just pork
like strips of pork it's pork on some
rice
it's a pork ball or a beef we're about
to show you okay so as the
good one that connor was talking about i
have some 7-eleven good on
right here so not a liar doesn't look
appetizing honestly
i have also never seen that before have
you ever seen this before it's it
honestly it [ __ ] slaps it tastes
great vertically to the camera okay
i can't show it vertically because it's
got it's got sources in it but look
what happens is that it comes it comes
with two compartments right
okay there we go there's juices
there's a lot of juices in here so what
happens is
it's basically just grilled like what is
it grilled
beef beef strips uh in whatever juices
they
cook it in and it comes with two
compartments ah that is
that is hot comes with a rice
compartment that's a common mistake that
people come to the rice compartment
or you can just dump it all on or you
can just take a piece at a time yeah
exactly whatever works best you've got
two compartments you can
eat it however you like i like to dump
i'll give it a shot the reason the
reason why they split it up is on this
[ __ ] as well
yeah some uh some like heat this is just
an excuse for us to uh film our eating
our dinners right
you know we're not gonna lie you can
tell this is like super cheap because
like it's
this beef is half just fat look at that
like that is you know the reason though
why they split it off
that's the good part you know the reason
why they split it up into two layers
though
so the rice doesn't soak up yeah yeah
yeah you wouldn't want the rice being
sorry
come on okay honestly if you come to
japan try the beef bowls because the
beef balls are
by far my favorite like 7-eleven
or whatever computer you decide well you
can go to the top three beef ball chains
oh yeah you could just go outside
they'll probably be at matsuyazukiya or
oh yeah
look at that it's it's my favorite cheap
japanese dish throw some of that on my
plate
yeah so do you get this often i get this
whenever
like i'm traveling and i just you can
never go wrong with beef balls yeah if i
have to get a meal in lawson's right
they basically do like uh
katsudon and they have like uh it's
really [ __ ] good really clean cuts it
on with just rice it's just like perfect
it's so good
and they give you like a [ __ ] ton as
well so good [ __ ] god you probably pound
that on there
i don't know i just like you you do like
you you don't you don't
i'm more you will be the final judge of
this because you love your people
you love your good ons probably by far
the most beef balls
gotta get the right ratio did you
actually like mayo with mine
you like mayo some of the chains will
give you mayo and sometimes it's so nice
to have mayo with it i know some people
think that's disgusting but
it really like because sometimes all
you're getting is just grease grease
grease and mayo helps like
i i always get mine with mayo yeah i
mean i like the fats i
i like but sometimes you need to like
mellow it out a little bit yeah but this
man doesn't like condiments so there's
nothing
he's talking about wow that's not bad
actually yeah it's good right and how
much is this
this is 400 yen it's four bucks this is
this is literally
yeah this is about four bucks and you
can get an entire meal and it [ __ ]
slaps like a one-off
it's pretty [ __ ] good yeah like if
you're desperate and you want a good
meal that's actually not bad
yeah i'm pretty surprised if the man
says so then it must be good
it is obviously you know if you go to
matsuya yoshinoya or whatever they
literally cook it in front of you yeah
like from
almost like this is this is like this is
not bad if you're if you're out about
and you just want a quick meal and you
you know can't you there's no mats here
or there's no like chain around you
look he's going on for seconds that's
how good it is that that's that says
more than
a little fatty but yeah that's pretty
actually i'd eat this would it be good
for with
some mayonnaise on it yeah but a managed
diet
yeah that's not bad points to 7-eleven
for that one i guess
yeah so there was tons of other hot food
that we couldn't get and also we just
don't want to waste all of it um
we don't want to throw away too much
food the staff is eating all of it don't
worry
so yeah i mean that's that's most the
hot food that we want to talk about
today yeah and the rest is just a bunch
of snacks
yeah there's the if there's one thing
that all three convenience stores have
it's snacks yeah
they have way more snacks they do hot
food i think oh way way more